luto en el mundo del fútbol a los 82
años falleció Edson arantes do
nacimiento Pelé en un hospital de la
ciudad de Sao Paulo tras más de un mes
de haber sido hospitalizado futbolistas
compañeros y jefes de estado rinden
tributo al rey del fútbol
Benjamín netanyahuya juramentó como
nuevo Primer Ministro de Israel luego de
que el parlamento le diera el voto de
confianza a su gobierno así comienza el
mandato que muchos analistas ven como el
más derechista de la historia del país y
que podría extender la ocupación en sus
Jordania
ataque masivo sobre Ucrania decenas de
miles de misiles de crucero cayeron
sobre ciudades principales como kiev y
harkid las fuerzas armadas ucranianas
afirman que el objetivo era la
infraestructura eléctrica tan solo en la
capital el 40% de la urbe se quedó sin
suministro
Bienvenidos a una actualización
informativa en Francia 24 yo soy Daniela
Blandón es un placer acompañarlos
iniciamos estas emisión informativa con
una noticia que enluta al mundo del
fútbol y es que este jueves a sus 82
años falleció Edson arantes do
nacimiento Pelé en un hospital de Sao
Paulo en donde era tratado por un cáncer
de colon recordemos en el siguiente
informe la vida y los logros del
considerado rey del balompié mundial
el rey del fútbol
de origen humilde Edson arantes do
nacimiento nació en tres corazones un
poblado a unos 200 kilómetros al este de
Sao Paulo el 23 de octubre de 1940 Los
Balones Ya rodaban en casa antes de
saber caminar su padre yo ahorramos do
nacimiento también fue futbolista
profesional la fama y el reconocimiento
llegaron pronto para él con tan solo 15
años debutó en uno de los clubes más
importantes de Brasil el Santos y con la
selección de su país se convirtió en el
jugador más joven en ganar un mundial
Aunque antes de los 20 años ya
deslumbraba al mundo se resistió a los
grandes equipos de Europa y permaneció
casi toda su carrera en el Santos de sus
amores un Idilio que solo fue
interrumpido para jugar dos años en el
cosmos de Nueva York en Estados Unidos
pisó la Casa Blanca varias veces y fue
uno de los impulsores del fútbol en ese
país en cuanto a las cifras Pelé rompió
todos los récords es actualmente el
máximo goleador de la selección de
Brasil con 77 tantos y el único jugador
en ganar tres mundiales fue considerado
por la FIFA como el mejor futbolista del
siglo XX
pese a ser una de las personas más
reconocidas del mundo Pelé siempre supo
gambear la polémica con muchos
admiradores y pocos detractores el rey
encarnó una figura entrañable en
Latinoamérica gracias a esa buena imagen
su relación con los organismos
internacionales siempre fue cercana tras
retirarse del fútbol en 1977 fue
nombrado embajador de las Naciones
Unidas e incluido en el comité de juego
limpio de la FIFA
incursionó en la política siendo
ministro de deportes de Brasil entre
1994 y 1998 durante la presidencia del
centrista Fernando Enrique Cardozo con
un registro difícil de igualar el rey
deja un legado lleno de historia y goles
un genio dentro y fuera de las canchas
[Música]
mi mamá
y estrellas del fútbol mundial han
comenzado a rendir tributo a Pelé Lionel
Messi y kilian mbappé protagonistas de
la más reciente final de la Copa del
Mundo dedicaron mensajes en sus redes
sociales al 10 brasileño
el rey del fútbol nos ha dejado pero su
legado nunca Se olvidará descansa en paz
rey
las reacciones también llegan por parte
de diferentes jefes de estado alrededor
del mundo el electo presidente de Brasil
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva quien
describió a Pelé como un jugador y un
brasileño que llevó el nombre del país
en alto
Belén nos dejó hoy se fue a compartir
mesa en el cielo con coutinho su gran
Compañero en el Santos ahora está en
compañía de muchas estrellas eternas
Didi garrincha niton Santos Sócrates
Maradona dejó una certeza nunca ha
habido un 10 como él Gracias Pelé y el
presidente de Francia Emmanuel macron
también dedicó un mensaje en sus redes
sociales a o Rey Pelé
el juego el rey la eternidad
cambiamos de información en Israel
Benjamín ajuya juramentó como nuevo
Primer Ministro del país y comienza así
su sexto mandato tras recibir el voto de
confianza del parlamento la
particularidad esta vez Es que la
coalición Que formó es la más derechista
que ha habido en la historia de israelí
está formada por partidos religiosos y
ultranacionalistas judíos y su partido
trazó como una prioridad de las
políticas públicas expandir los
asentamientos en cisjordania en los
territorios que los palestinos
consideran como propios y en
asentamientos que la ONU tilda de
ilegales lo que podría agravar el
conflicto palestino israelí
la primera misión es frustrar los
esfuerzos de Irán por desarrollar un
arsenal de armas nucleares que nos
amenazaría a nosotros y al mundo entero
la segunda misión es desarrollar la
infraestructura del país la tercera
misión es continuar ampliando el círculo
de paz los Países Árabes para poner fin
al conflicto árabe israelí Estas son las
tres misiones nacionales
está claro que un gobierno dirigido por
netanyahu e integrado por smotrich y
bengavir como miembros seguramente
creará políticas mucho más provocativas
está manipulando detonadores ya sea
tratando de cambiar el estatus quo de la
mezquita alaxa La locura de los
asentamientos que ya lo manifestaron o
la agresión contra los prisioneros
y en noticias de la guerra en Ucrania
kiev en la capital de este país
no fue la única ciudad afectada por los
más recientes ataques aéreos masivos de
Rusia en el Oeste El vive también fue
bombardeada y en el este Odessa harquif
y saporilla los ataques se producen Un
día después de que Rusia rechazara la
propuesta de paz de Ucrania Samuel
Salgado nos amplía
estelas de humo en los cielos de kiev
evidencia en una nueva oleada de ataques
aéreos rusos sobre la capital ucraniana
el enemigo lanzó un ataque masivo en el
territorio ucraniano en el que se
lanzaron misiles de cruceros desde el
aire y el mar así como misiles de avión
s-300 y s-400 dirigidos a objetivos
críticos y de infraestructura energética
en regiones del este centro oeste y sur
de nuestro país
el enemigo utilizó más de 69 misiles la
defensa aérea de nuestro país destruyó
54 misiles
los residentes de kiev se refugiaron de
nuevo en las estaciones subterráneas del
metro muchos de ellos no tienen
calefacción y suministro de energía en
sus casas debido a que los constantes
ataques han afectado la red eléctrica
del país
tras los ataques de este jueves un 40%
de la urbe quedó sin servicio eléctrico
harquif la segunda ciudad del país
también fue blanco de los cohetes rusos
y al sureste en saporilla algunos
residentes resultaron damnificados
me desperté con todo temblando
desmoronándose
estos ataques masivos tienen lugar Un
día después de que Rusia rechazara la
propuesta de paz de diez puntos del
presidente bolodimircelenski el kremlin
insiste en que cualquier intento de paz
debe reconocer la soberanía rusa de
crimea jerson saporilla Daniel
ucranianos anexados ilegalmente por
Rusia el Ministerio de relaciones
exteriores de Rusia se pronunció al
respecto
consideramos esto como una idea tan
delirante y otro truco publicitario de
Washington que ha estado tratando
recientemente de presentar al régimen de
kiev como un pacificador
al igual que esta puesta de paz
rechazada otros intentos de menguar la
guerra tampoco han tenido éxito como la
creación de una zona desmilitarizada en
la central nuclear de saporilla la más
grande de Europa para evitar una
eventual catástrofe radioactiva debido a
los bombardeos de ambos bandos
seguimos hablando de la guerra velar uso
sostiene que derribó un misil s-300 que
pertenecería a las fuerzas armadas
ucranianas por eso el Ministerio de
relaciones exteriores bielorruso convocó
al embajador de Ucrania en Minsk y
gorricasim para exigirle que investigue
quién lanzó el proyectil y adopte
medidas para evitar que un incidente así
se repita los militares de velarus
precisaron que su defensa antiaérea
evitó que el misil impactara en el
pueblo de corbata que queda a unos 20
kilómetros de la frontera con Ucrania
alrededor de las 10 a.m en el distrito
detectamos la fragmentación de un
supuesto misil s300 de las fuerzas arma
ucranianas la situación se parece mucho
a la que ocurrió recientemente con la
caída de un misil similar en el
territorio de la República de Polonia
así llegamos al final de esta emisión
informativa quédense con nosotros
[Música]